[Music]
so bills it's the weekend
different for us dom different normally
it's a tuesday or wednesday right
yeah normally our tuesday or wednesday
wednesday is taking up with driving to
the studio and sitting down and doing
the podcast together
unfortunately or fortunately maybe uh
we're in different cities in different
parts of the world so we're doing it uh
via our our computers but
this week has a little
weekendy chill out kind of vibe going on
i don't know if you've seen my balls but
my balls seem very
settled today they're just sat there in
a lovely triangle formation
it's as if no one's touched them all
weekend i haven't touched my balls since
probably
thursday and i regret wow i regret when
i did touch them uh on thursday because
i hit them really hard
with that stick you were telling me
about yeah really hard with a stick but
it didn't it didn't really uh
do me any favors i didn't feel like my
balls behaved any better after i whacked
him really hard so the next time i hit
my balls i might hit him a little gentle
well it's nice to see your balls sitting
exactly where they should be now thank
you john
what about you what have you been up to
this this weekend have you been out and
about
well i'll tell you what i have i've been
doing a few before i saw you john
there's a few errands to run and i got
the messages in i know you like that the
scottish uh going out and getting the
messages which is going for your
shopping and a few other errands but
here's the thing tom
if if you don't have a pen and paper
handy
when you're um when when you've got the
messages or errands to do i found a new
thing that you can do dumb and i'll just
show you here and all you really need is
a
drum machine and that can help you
remember everything you need to get
just like that's done
spreads bread
fabric conditioner spending money runny
honey eggs
toilet paper that can wait to later a
tangerine sausage roll from greg's
and that's all it takes tom
brilliant so yeah that was that was your
list how many i think they were i think
i counted nine how many of those
uh things that you wanted to do did you
actually strike off your list today
well i got eight of them done because um
i didn't get the sausage roll from
greg's because uh i couldn't find the
greg's over here and i used to enjoy it
greg's
greg's quite an interesting phenomenon
don't you think it's
i would argue
britain's most famous bakery but no one
buys bread from greg's what you buy
is sausage rolls pies pasties and maybe
some cakes right
you're right don and here's a story from
greg's
a friend of mine who will remain
nameless
went to greg's
got a steak bake
enjoyed this steak bake
as a young lady she's on the way
to us as suntan
parlour you know where they have the sun
beds and you can get a tan when you're
in scotland and she's eating this steak
bake
when she gets to this place and they're
unmanned
you just go in and you put the money in
the sun bed you've got a room of your
own and you lie there and get your tan
and you leave there's no one there
she went in
at steak bake put the money in lay down
oh our stomach started to go the state
bake and the heat the heat the the thing
i think was too much for the the new
steak bake in her belly
oh
no what am i going to do and she's naked
of course she's getting a suntan
and there was a bucket
and and she she just went to the bucket
dome and she she let herself go and in
the bucket after the steak bake
and then she just basically cleaned
herself off and off she went and left
the bucket there what do you think of
that
it's unfortunate for the cleaning crew
that comes in maybe a day later or a
couple of days later just to make sure
that everything's fine for the next
client and they find a bucket of [__]
do you think maybe as you think that
somebody's tan had just fell off into
the bucket
it's a sad story anyway moving on dumb
it is just to finish that story for any
of our listeners or viewers out there
that are not fully aware of what a steak
bake is just break that down for people
a snake break is basically like i think
it's kind of like a steak pie and a sort
of um puff pastry isn't it yeah so uh
you you've got like steak and maybe
onions and a little bit of gravy inside
a puff pastry
don't eat before you go to your sun tan
bed no no
never never do that never eat yellow
snow
when i want to read a new book or maybe
listen to an audiobook or possibly even
explore the world of podcasts i head to
script it's fantastic dom whenever i
need a new book they help me find the
one i like you know i like science books
i've got a lot at script with scribd the
world's most fascinating library is
entirely at your fingertips all for just
9.99 a month you can enjoy instant
access to scribs entire library for less
than the cost of one single book right
now scribd is offering our listeners a
free 60 day trial go to try dot script
dot com slash onion for your free trial
that's try.scribd.com
onion to get 60 days of scribd for free
i'll tell you my favorite uh butcher
joke which you know it's a classic one
a man comes into the butcher's and says
hey where's your assistant that you had
here last week and the butcher says i
caught him with his dick
inside the bacon slicer
and the man said oh my god
what did you do with a bacon slice there
and he said i fired her as
well we might need a few bleeps on that
one
yeah
[__] sweet johnny clues
[__]
i just checked my pocket and realized
that my earring is in
my pocket because i was cleaning my ears
earlier on with salt water
yeah because if yeah look tiny little
hearing because if you um
if you don't clean your ears every so
often especially the little hole the new
little hole in your ear yeah it can get
a little you know not nasty or naughty
or gunky so
it's not just you don't want that you
don't want seepage you don't want
seepage so you get a little bit of uh
salt i keep missing my ear hole i said
ear hole
um
you get a little bit of salt and a
little bit of hot water yeah and you
melt the
salt
in some hot water
and
then you just kind of
swish that around your ear
oh i can't do it it's gonna make my ear
bleed i don't
it could be a two-man job that i'll i'll
help you with that when you come home
don't you worry i think a lot of a lot
of girls are very good at putting
earrings in without needing
you know a visual aid like a mirror but
when you've first done it i've no i've
never had the piercing
yeah i remember saying to you back when
i got mine that i was very surprised
that in the 80s
you didn't do it
well
i never yeah it never occurred to me did
you have your ears pierced when you were
younger as well no no this is the first
time i first pierced my ear when i was
44. um wow yeah i still can't i still
can't i think um
i think uh
billy connolly got his nipples pierced
for his 50th
if i remember right yeah and supposedly
when he so maybe you can do that
supposedly when he got it done
the guy who pierced his nipples said to
billy connolly there you go
one more of us one lesser
that's than
i love that i can't get it in yeah i'll
fuss about that but i told you about it
well it's not about tidying my house so
do you know that um right
do you know that kind of quite renowned
thai
buddhist monk that oprah winfrey is
quite good friends with it he's done it
he's he's written a few books he does he
shaves his head he's probably in his
early 60s now i think he's called
he's got like a
triple barrelled name is like is it
t snap hang might be him john i'm sure
johnny johnny close could find out if he
goes on to google
and and searches um
oprah winfrey's thai buddhist monk
friend or whatever
it's probably i think it's probably
teach niche tan but i don't know if
that's how you see it yes
i think you are right
um but he wrote a fantastic book um has
written quite a few great books but rob
wrote a book i can't remember but
the name of it but in the book he talks
about
washing the dishes and he says if you're
gonna wash the dishes
then wash the dishes with 100 of your
being and 100 of your presents and wash
the best
dishes that you've ever washed and enjoy
and enjoy the experience and blah blah
blah
and uh i remember that really light
resonated with me years ago and
back when i was a kid like tidying the
house being forced by my parents to tidy
my room or tiny parts of the house was
like
the worst thing that could ever happen
to me and after reading that guy's book
i just flipped that switch of like okay
now try and get enjoyment out of the
process not just having a tidy house but
the process of cleaning the house so
today
went to the gym tied in my house and it
was a joyful experience
but putting that earring in your ears
not that joyful
it hurts just enjoy it yeah i just
enjoyed it
i'm trying this just can't find the hole
i don't know it's
tricky
yeah it's not easy are you trying are
you doing it while looking at yourself
do it it's like backwards in the camera
so when i go left it goes right
i mean hang on i'll be back it's the
same as see when you draw a sword dom
when you draw a sword i'll just tell the
audience because you're off to do
something if you draw a sword and then
you're trying to put the sword back into
your scabbard or whatever it's called
don't look at the scabbard or whatever
it's called
you just do it like
by kind of feeling the sword not the
sharp end and then put it back in the
scabbard don't look because if you're
looking you'll all go wrong and that's
probably the same if you're trying to
insert um
an earring into uh your new ear hole
it's so much easier doing it in a mirror
when you can get up close than doing it
in a webcam but we got there eventually
um
have you got one of those like shaving
mirrors that makes everything really big
yeah terrifying as well yeah three times
magnification around your eyes can look
very strange sometimes
it's not great is it it's not falling
apart
between all the trolls and dragons it's
important to have the right insurance in
middle earth but comparing insurance
companies online can take longer than
talking to an ent and that is where the
zebra comes in
with the zebra you can compare car and
home quotes from every major insurance
company in under five minutes giving you
all the facts you need to make the right
decision it's the fastest way to find
the right coverage at the right price
and will help you find a provider that
you can trust in fact the zebra saves
people an average of 922
a year on home and auto combined and
that'll buy a flagging of the only brew
for the brave and true from your local
green dragon it just makes finding
insurance so much easier with everything
right there at your fingertips storm
sometimes looking for insurance can be a
real hard thing to do the zebra makes it
much easier save time and money in
minutes compare quotes for free at the
zebra.com slash onion that's the
zebra.com
a healthy digestive system is extremely
important and the science is clear a
healthy gut microbiome with the good
bacteria that helps our bodies process
food is key to a healthy lifestyle over
time people with type 2 diabetes lose
the gut bacteria that helps digest fiber
and manage our blood glucose levels for
those with type 2 diabetes diet and
exercise are incredibly important but
sometimes something else to help would
be good as well and we would encourage
our listeners to learn how pendulum
glucose control can help pendulum's team
of scientists doctors and innovators
isolated the unique strain of beneficial
gut bacteria that help people with type
2 diabetes manage their blood sugar
levels take control of your glucose
levels today try pendulum glucose
control for 90 days if you're not
satisfied with your levels you'll get
your money back
visit
pendulumlife.com to find out more and
use promo code onion for 20 off your
first bottle of membership that's p e n
d u l u m
l i f e
dot com
promo code onion
[Music]
oh i remembered what i was gonna uh tell
you we have a
a guest today we've been doing this um
semi-regular section of the show where
we talk to someone who has
an interesting job um
um
fantastic was
jolly jobs
um jolly jobs quirky working it worked
reset one on quirky working quirky
working when did we settle on a question
working i think but wasn't there a few
more we had quirky work it jake jay
perry jobs or something like that or
jokey jobs
jobs i don't know
interesting industry vivid vocations we
had a few i think um
anyway
today fabulous foreign
today's wonderful guest has been working
in the zoo industry for almost 10 years
a lady called kayla cosmi from texas so
should we get her in and see if she can
uh wow please animal knowledge hello
kayla hello and welcome to the
friendship onion i'm so happy to be here
and not gonna lie i'm a little bit
fangirling right now i love it good god
that's good to hear
so you've been working with animals for
uh many years yes and specifically these
last few years on chickens a type of
chicken is that correct
um that was about four or five years ago
and now it's actually more recently
primates so mostly gorillas
could you could you quickly tell us the
story of the chickens which i read in
your um
the the breakdown of what you've been up
to that i found really interesting uh
could you give us a little bit of
history of that
for sure so and there's uh it's called
the atwaters prairie chicken they are
native to here um in texas and they have
pretty much almost gone extinct in the
wild and because of the zoo that i work
at as well as a couple of other zoos um
we've worked together on a breeding
program to help raise them and then
eventually once when they're ready we
will release them back out into the wild
incredible so how did these
specific chickens become endangered down
in in texas
so kind of like the dodo bird i kind of
like to
refer to them as the texas dodo bird um
they were just over hunted um just by
native that everyone that came here um
or back in the early days and just that
was their main source of food and they
were over hunted
oh and how was it
to be delicious oh i was gonna say how
sorry bills um like how would how would
they differ from a regular kind of
farmyard chicken that maybe we're a
little bit more accustomed to
so
they're more considered a grouse easily
even though they're like they have
chicken in the name they're more closely
related to like a turkey or a pheasant
ah a bit bigger
so how did you before we get on to what
you're doing now how did you
initially get involved with animals and
dom is a good one to talk to and this
could because obviously he's um the
animal expert
right but um how did you how did your
interest did you grow up in a farm or
something i didn't actually um i just
i've always grown up loving animals i
had a dog growing up and i was just
always so interested in him like i would
just do everything like inspecting him
like playing with them training him and
whatnot
and so then i was actually going down
the vet route i wanted to be a
veterinarian and once when i
ended up getting an internship at the
zoo
um i realized i'd rather
work with the animals
rather than kind of more medically i
didn't want to go that route because
i saw kind of
more like the
the everyday of that wasn't exactly
fulfilling that passion in me whereas
whenever i was um an intern at the zoo
working with teaching other kids about
these animals and like inspiring that
passion for them that i had that made a
huge impact on me and so i wanted to
kind of go that route instead ah which
sounds kind of like what dom did with
his show
well things which was
i mean you can talk about this dom but
it was sort of about
educating people about animals that a
lot of people don't like right
snakes and
spiders
yeah
any anything that
anything that needs uh help more because
maybe they're shunned or ignored or
uh vilified i
was always a fan of and can continue to
be it's interesting cause i think
so many kids growing up that are hugely
passionate about animals the first thing
that they kind of
fantasize over in terms of a job is
usually being a zookeeper that was my
thing too i just thought a zookeeper was
like the most glamorous
job in the world you get to choose from
hundreds of different animals that you
can
interact with on a on a daily basis and
just continually feed
that passion and then as you grow up you
realize that it's obviously
a heck of a lot of work but like like
you said kayla i'm sure probably the
difference between working at a zoo and
being a veterinarian most veterinarians
certainly working zoos are usually kind
of treating animals the unwell and need
help as opposed to
you know helping them out in their daily
lifetime thing um
right exactly and now you work with
primates i mean i have a
i have an interesting
feeling about primates
in zoos because
obviously breeding programs in zoos are
are extremely important and and need as
much help as we can give them especially
with a lot of these vulnerable animals
um
the best news for me are ones that you
know
obviously allow people to see animals
and be educated on animals but have a
very
uh
serious breeding program um
primates in zoos can can sometimes
struggle huh with with what that
can mean for their for their life
obviously the zoos make it as as
pleasant as possible for them but
like how do you find gorillas seem to um
behave in captivity as opposed to what
we've what we've witnessed of them doing
in the wild
so they
the gorillas that specifically i work
with um funny enough whenever
kovid really hit and we had to shut down
and not have any guests they actually
showed signs of missing people they were
kind of looking around for them and
whatnot um but to this like opposite of
that as well is that some of the other
animals um
they kind of got used to it again and so
then whenever we started having people
come back um there was kind of like oh
people are back but otherwise they don't
really care less about people at least
for gorillas whereas like the chimps or
orangutans they are more people oriented
um so they're more interested in our
guests and they'll interact with them at
the windows
um
and so it's interesting to kind of
had seen that dynamic change between
them but um after us and in general we
really focus on a lot of um enrichment
for the primates so that's um
stimulating just that natural behavior
for them or also just giving them
um like different
puzzles that they have to figure out and
they really they're very smart smarter
than
most people think and they a lot of
people get shocked whenever we will call
their names out and they're like wait
they know their names we're like yeah
like it's
kind of like your dog if you call out
your dog's name
just people don't make that connection
all the time and it's very funny to see
that
right yeah the difference between a pet
and an actual yeah i feel one
so and for for people who aren't experts
like me what makes a primate well how
when when you put something in the
the list of primates what makes a
primate a primate
so there are
a couple different so humans are kind of
considered primates as well so there's
um so
non-human primates so we have the great
apes which are going to be
um gorillas orangutans chimpanzees and
bonobos and then you also have lesser
apes which are going to be the more
gibbon species right and then you have
um
tamarinds and then just old world
monkeys new world monkeys so they're
gonna
the difference between apes and monkeys
are gonna be
tail versus no tail
um and then you're also going to
see um size wise as well so apes are
going to be a lot larger than monkeys
right okay um
and then you also have like even the
smaller monkeys so tamarinds and lemurs
are the
um
i always get wrong with this
pronunciation so
persimmon i believe don may help me here
yeah
i feel like persimmon is also a
oh my goodness
i don't think it's a fruit
oh that's the truth yeah that's a
persimmon right a salmon is a fruit yes
oh the english language is so
complicated
so what's the name of the um the place
where you're working just now down in
texas
who's that all right okay lovely yes so
that's quite a big um
place then is it it's like it is so we
are
size wise um our zoo is actually not
very big compared to like comparatively
speaking
um but we are one of the most visited
zoos in the us right okay
do you know how many and then our
biggest
so i'm sorry kayla i was going to say do
you know how many guesses
you would get on an average day
oh
so with covet it's kind of changed
because we've had to limit the amount
so i'm
i'm not 100 sure on how much from the
top of my head okay that's all right um
i know it's a lot i was gonna i was
gonna tell you i don't know if you if
you play computer games or have done
anything like that but during
lockdown coveted lockdown because of my
constant fascination with animals and
probably my childhood obsession with
being a zookeeper i started playing a
zoo simulation game called planet zoo
where you know you can either
start with an unlimited amount of money
and do whatever you want or you can be
kind of bound by this budget and try and
build a bigger and
bigger zoo so
i started with a budget
and did watched all these tutorials and
watched all these youtube oh by the way
it just works out what jumper i'm
wearing look at this jumper today i
didn't even know that we were chatting
to you and i'm wearing
a
grenade that crazy
yeah and i pointed out your um your
mandrel shirt i guess whatever a couple
weeks ago
that you were wearing oh yeah my like
pixelated mandrel mandrels used to scare
the heck at me when i was a kid i just
that facial coloring just really used to
unnerve me
um
i got to work with one briefly oh wow
but they're they're really cool yeah
they're very cool so i'll try and finish
this story really quickly but um
the so
this
this zoo
where i got this budget
i watched this tutorial that said if you
get a very simple animal to work with
like tortoises and maybe ostriches or
emus and then obviously this is in the
game let them breed and keep their
offspring safe then you can sell their
offspring and then with the profits you
can eventually buy things like snow
leopards and elephants and tigers and
orangutans and gorillas and all this
kind of stuff i was like oh this is this
is brilliant i'll just tick away at this
so
all
my
tortoises
and my ostriches
but i accidentally forgot to put a
a door for the zookeeper to get into my
ostrich enclosure so my ass switches
i heard about people doing that weren't
being watered
and the heat went off so they all died
and then uh my tortoise is bred out of
control and i had nowhere to store them
so i had to rip up my zoo and start
again and i was really upset it was so
funny during when we're all in lockdown
and stuff i used to love watching dom on
instagram asking questions of why why
why are my ostriches all dying and you
know people would say well there's no
door in your cage or there's no there's
no walkway for people to get into ah i
used to need stitches yeah it's great
brilliant um
it's really good so don't don't let dom
run your zoo no doubt i've heard really
good things about it i've had fellow
zookeepers play it as well and actually
one of them had the same issue happen is
like they didn't have some type of
doorway and they're like wait i can't
give up the animal
it is a fantastic game planet zoo and
and since making those mistakes i have
played it to a point now where i have
like giraffes and a train that goes
through the park and
you know crazy amount of guests going
through and crazy amount of money it
just
in the first couple of times that you
try it
you're always gonna make mistakes and it
doesn't tell you what you should or
shouldn't be doing but anyway we should
talk about real zoos caleb
and the note scaler says that um
as well as looking after the animals and
teaching them and stuff you you also
teach the guests
how they can help um animals in the wild
right so that's actually a big focus of
our zoo is that we want to connect our
guests with animals in the wild so that
way they know
like just by them visiting they
uh their proceed of their
tickets actually go to we have a couple
of um actually quite a few conservation
partners that are actually out in the
field
um that we help fund um for them to
either
help animals actually in the wild so by
helping them like vets and stuff there
or a lot of the times they're even
raising awareness to locals on like how
to coexist with them
and what they can do to help um
save them as well like replanting trees
and whatnot ah fantastic i mean i think
that's really important how to do that
sort of work
if you're if you're working with the
animals and over here so that's that's a
great thing to hear is that a map i see
in the background there kayla is that a
map of them is that where me and dom
were hiking mountains etc
it is i have it's huge and then i also
have um
aragorn sword so andrew and then there's
the
gundor flag and then over here i have
gandalf's staff
and then the rohan i guess you can't see
it but there is a rohan banner as well
oh so great this room that i'm in we
call it our tribute room because it's
pretty much the whole house it has
little lord of the rings stuff here and
there so anytime that people come over
i'm like there's easter eggs in this
house so just have fun looking for them
i love it well maybe do you have any
questions you want to ask either me or
dom dom as well as being an expert in
animals is also an expert in the land of
rohan of course
so i do actually um so one's like a more
personal question um because i know both
of y'all like food
um
and like cooking and stuff is there any
signature dish that you're known for
that you really love to make
done
um
it would probably have mermaid in it for
sure i am a fan i am a fan
um i do a pretty good
spanish omelette which over in spain
they called tortilla
obviously different from the tortillas
that we might know in
england or the united states a tortilla
in spain is like
really thinly sliced potatoes
with onions and some saffron if you're
feeling a little saucy and then you cook
those up in a pan and when they're just
done
you crack a whole bunch of eggs in them
and stir them around
then you cook that
flip the pan
cook the bottom part but not for as long
so you want the gooey part to be a
little bit
um
yeah not not coming apart when you cook
it but just have a little give to it i'm
quite good at a spanish omelet but i
don't tend to eat too many eggs so it's
kind of a
few times a year thing but when i do it
i smash it i used to be incredibly
famous
kayla for my um red
thai curry which i make completely from
scratch but i haven't done that for a
while but um you've made me think about
it again so maybe maybe i'll do that get
the stuff in today when i'm out shopping
in terms of food pictures
in terms of kayla
um just to go back to the zoo thing for
for a minute i know you said you've been
working with gorillas for a while
um is there a certain food that you know
gets the strongest reaction out of
gorillas generally or are there
different individual tastes for
different gorillas
there is different individual tastes for
dislikes for sure um but for sure
bananas are the favorite
as well as frozen grapes and
so gorillas will actually do this
humming whenever they eat
or like whenever they're about to eat
and any time that they have seen kale i
have never heard the building so loud
with all the humming that was going on
because they were just so excited about
kale wow
yeah kale
so we get about 50 pounds give or take
um
per
day for each of our groups so we have
two different groups um and so they get
lots of greens
fantastic it's interesting it's amazing
and it amazes me that they get to that
size
because we are we and in our heads isn't
it when we
we see bodybuilders and things you think
of oh they're eating red meat and blah
blah blah but gorillas eat bananas and
grapes and
they're they're huge
it shows you maybe they're strictly
vegetarian yeah it's crazy isn't it yeah
i think there's a lot of about nutrition
that we don't quite get yet huh
and their digestive tract is a little
bit different than ours
um so they do process some of that food
a little bit differently okay um but
yeah for us to not be so
um different
yeah it's amazing that just solid muscle
from all that i remember i went to
uh i went to rwanda kayla to see the
gorillas uh twice and outside of it just
been an amazing
you know
hike into the forest you know being
around the gorillas was
something that you'd never forget but
one of the things that stood out about
them
is how much they farted
yo
yes it is it's really bad um and
every single time i do it even though we
hear it all day every day
all of us can't help but laugh because
it's just it is funny and we're like
come on
because i mean if you're in the middle
of like sitting in front of them feeding
them or doing like a training session
and they pass gas
you have to sit there and just take it
and sometimes it can be very potent yes
that's a good fact yeah i was lucky i
was outside obviously wild gorillas but
i think we both times there was no less
than probably
eight and i think the first time there
was probably closer to 12 of them and
with that number it was almost kind of
constant you know i mean there wasn't a
point too long
where one of the gorillas wasn't farting
uh which i just absolutely loved it was
like a monty python sketch but some of
the some of the tourists around me you
know because we were in a group of other
people
they were just completely flummoxed by
like where's where's that noise coming
from the keeper's like it's
our guide
constantly amazing i completely believe
it amazing
if someone relies on your financial
support
whether it's a child or an aging parent
or even a
business partner
you need life insurance
life insurance can give you peace of
mind that if something happens to you
your loved ones would have a financial
cushion to pay for things like rent or
mortgage payments
loans or even education head to
policygenius.com onion and answer a few
questions about yourself
in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance coverage you need and
compare personalized quotes to find your
best price
you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius policy genius
works for you not the insurance
companies
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
or sell your info to third parties head
to policygenius.com
onion to get your free life insurance
quotes and see how much you could save
that's policy genius dot com slash onion
to start comparing quotes and simplify
insurance banning check out policy
genius
policy genius.com
onion thanks to policy genius for
sponsoring
reserve bar is the online source of
premium and luxury spirits wine and
champagne
visit
reservebar.com to create the perfect
home bar or have the ideal gift
delivered it's also where you find the
best in new and hard to find bottles and
those celebrity spirits that you've been
wanting to try no one does spirits
gifting better than reserve bar have a
bottle custom engraved with a name date
or logo to create the perfect gift and
you can build your dream home bar at
reserve bar just select the spirits wine
and bubbly you love they've also got
glassware and mixing tools as well
should you need them reserve bar offers
the cocktail lounge your online source
for inspiring new cocktail recipes and
the stories behind your favorite brand
visit reservebar.com today and use the
promo code onion to save ten dollars off
your purchase of 75 or more on spirits
wines or pre-made cocktails but only
when you use our special offer at
reservebar.com with code onion that's
reservedbar.com and code onion this
offer expires december 31st 2021
i did have one other question for y'all
in regards to the movie yeah
so in fellowship of the ring
um
you're thrown an apple and i think i'm
like you catch it but then the second
apple that gets thrown i think billy it
hits you in the head
was that intentional or was that
an accident no it was intentional they
they
i can't even remember whose idea it was
but the idea was that you know
aragorn is heading over the hill and
doesn't want us to stop and as hobbits
we're like well we've only had one
breakfast that's you know second
breakfast it's time for us to stop and
cook up and so as he's walking he just
throws a couple of apples over for me
and dom
and dom being a little smarter catches
his and
the idea is that i don't i'm just
looking around you know and i get it in
the head and and then i actually look up
to see where the apple came from you
know so
yeah it was it was planned but it got
and it was it was um
it was viggo who was throwing it from
behind camera and he was loving it he
was in stitches hitting me in the head
they must have done it about 20 times
you know
well i love how you carried that over
into two towers because all of a sudden
whenever the apples are floating i see
you look up again and i'm like i love
that carryover oh i forgot i've done
that that's funny oh well done nice it's
been a long time that was a fun day
wasn't it though oh it was a great day
it's been a long time since i've seen
that scene but from my
recollection
one one apple gets
thrown over by aragorn
and mary catches the first one
and then does he pass it to pippin and
give him a little pat on the shoulder
and say there you go there's your second
breakfast there's the answer to our
query
we're moving on so i think
yep like mary isn't aware that aragorn
is going to throw two he thinks that
arrogance you know
throws one and then that's the end
and moves on otherwise i think if mary
would have been there
one of them
would have seen the apple come in their
way and grabbed it but you look down at
the apple and that's when the second one
hits you right oh and that's when it
said ah right
that was fun that was a fun day
i'm obsessed with apples so i've managed
i've managed to in some way have apples
either intentionally or unintentionally
been crowbarred into a lot of
projects that i've done just because
like if someone were to say to me in a
in a tv show or a film
we're doing a scene and in this scene
you have to eat something pick it i
would always pick an apple because i
could probably eat 10 apples no problem
doesn't bother me
oh my goodness yeah i get so full off of
apples i can barely finish one i love
him i love him
yeah
i get that off my mom now how do how do
um gorillas feel about apples or
primates in general i mean most primates
are big fans of fruit and most monkeys
especially new monkeys are massive fans
of fruit right
yes yeah they love apples and actually
that's one of my favorite things to
listen to them too because
you know if any like person was to be
eating and like they're snacking i'm
like it's it's annoying but anytime like
the gorillas or any of the other
primates that i work with they're
sitting there smacking those apples i'm
like oh so cute
so what do you think about when me and
dom do billy and all meet the world and
we are a little close to the
the microphones that we've really split
the world here right down the middle of
people who enjoy
domestication and others who do not want
it at all where do you sit there kayla
i think that you'll tastefully do it
to where it makes it
entry like you're like oh i do want to
try that so you'll make the food more
enticing so i i thought i laughed
whenever people you've made mention that
people can't stand it and i'm like i
actually enjoy it like it doesn't bother
me right we're going with you kayla
that's it you've you've decided for us
yeah i mean
and just to
just to um chime in there i want i do
want to make two points first one is
neither billy or i
ever make noise while we're eating
we we don't eat like that normally we're
only putting those noises on for a
podcast i would hate to think bills if
you and i sat down at a restaurant
a couple comes in that listens to the
podcast and they say oh no put us put us
on the other side of the restaurant
because we've heard these guys eat
that's not how we eat normally we are we
are literally grabbing the microphone
and going
oh i can tell because i usually watch
y'all on youtube and so i can tell like
there is it's intentional so doing it
very intentionally um i think it's funny
but there is a comment here from youtube
from
marion taj kaya i hope i got that name
wrong uh right i'll probably get it
wrong
who says my vote on the mastication
debate no events taken definitely needs
definitely adds to the experience don't
be shy i love the show so
marion
loves it too there you go caleb
there you go it's a double up so that is
that we'll be chewing even more well
about the same from now on perfect until
it's been an absolute treat
before you go i just wanted to ask you
said that you had aragorn sword is it
shards of his sword or is it the whole
sword
it's the whole sword and then i also do
have two replicas of sting
nice
so one of them lights up it's more
plastic and then the other one is an
actual yeah
wow all right cool well it's really nice
to meet you kayla
all right nice meeting y'all too thank
you kayla take it easy have a great day
bye bye thanks
billy and dom eat the world
well that was the lovely charming and
fantastic
kayla lovely stuff tom very interesting
interesting work that she's doing i like
the idea of the chickens that she she
brought back to texas
bring chickens back to texas i see well
it must be fantastic as an animal lover
growing up like i said i think most
animal lovers
kind of
fantasize about being zookeepers and
working with animals and working with a
variety of animals but not that many
people
actually get a chance to work in zoos
but also affect a certain
animal's
life you know like their their actual
history on planet earth those prairie
chickens have been affected by the work
that kayla and her staff do because
probably if they hadn't done anything
within you know 30 40 50 years we might
not
have them and all animals are important
and special so
what a great job yeah no it's a great
thing but i think actually working in a
zoo like that is probably easier than
the online zoo that you've had a
terrible time with don which is probably
more difficult
very very difficult indeed it's actually
made me starving hungry uh
thinking about all the failings uh that
i've gone through with that zoo and with
that in mind should we eat the world
billy and tom eat the world tom here we
go what are we having this week well
i i would like to
say that uh for the past three weeks
running i think i've been slightly
spoiled because
um
we did guinness one week which is a big
favorite drink of mine we did marmite
which got a perfect score not too long
ago
unbelievable yeah unbelievable this week
we're featuring one of my favorite
condiments of all time and one of yours
coleman's
english mustard
and a dog bob has came to say hi hi bob
yep i got a squeezy one oh
nice
i've never really seen that before no
when we had this in the house when i was
a kid yeah it was it was a thing of
powder it was a powder
the powder had to mix it up do you get
do you ever get it that way the powder
is still available
and uh johnny clues our producer prefers
the powder to anything else and i've
used the powder at times in certain
recipes that ask for more of a dry
feeling to the mustard as opposed to
this mustard which i believe is mixed
with a little bit of vinegar is that
right
water oh no so the ingredients of our
mustard or at least mine here
water mustard flour which is the the
powder that we know sugar salt a little
bit of wheat
turmeric very very good for you indian
spice full of healthy
foods citric acid which is lemon juice
and xanthian gum which gives me the
heebie-jeebies but everything else
super-duper
because i can remember in our house my
dad taking a little s
during dinner a little bit the powder
and then adding water i suppose and
stand up and he'd put that on everything
i don't really use it but um i'll try it
today
yeah what are you going to try on
because english mustard uh which which
is very different from american classic
mustard like french's mustard it's
really quite strong like american
mustard you put on hot dogs and have
with you know chips and french fries and
stuff yeah really doesn't seem to have
that much of a kick to it but english
mustard i would say is about as hot if
not hotter than wasabi right right
it's got a sort of wasabi kind of feel
to it right yeah it does i'm going to
put it on this piece of cheese dom i
don't know if that's right or wrong but
that's what i'm going to do let me give
you let me read you another
blurb about mustard whilst you get your
piece of cheese ready
so it says here mustard has been one of
the most widely grown and used spices in
the world for many centuries is believed
to have originated in ancient egypt the
greeks used mustard as a medicine and a
spice the romans emulated the groups
greeks using it as both food and
medicine as well as ascribing it as a
cure for anything from hysteria
to snakebite to bubonic plague the
romans brought mustard to northern
france where it eventually became
cultivated by monks and by the 9th
century monastery monasteries were
producing considerable amounts of income
from sales
of mustard well tom that's all very
interesting i like that people so they
used to use it as like a medicine
yeah to treat hysteria right here i'm
going to try it snake bite and beat
bonnet plate try it um
i mean english helps a lot of things
english mustard definitely my favorite
type of mustard in the world i would
describe it as really quite hot
william well it's quite intense
i'm having it on a piece of apple i
definitely yeah on a piece of apple
that's a good idea i'll try it on a
piece of bread now mm-hmm hold on
i mean how do you even go about
explaining the flavor mustard aside from
saying the flavor is hot i mean it's um
i mean it's about it is like the sort of
wasabi thing isn't it very wasabi-like
is it
catches um
catches in the back of your throat quite
easily and into your nasal passages but
wasabi is actually a type of horseradish
not related to mustard mustard is a
completely different spice altogether
but this is it really is helping this
cheese dom i'll give you some more um
facts here mustard
was introduced into england in the 12th
century
and in early times seeds were coarsely
ground at the table using a mortar and
it was eaten in this rough state
it reached the northeast by about 1486
that took a while didn't it yeah like
two to 250 years to get up to the
northeast well
anyway when monks on the fame island
which was a monastic cell tied to durham
cathedral are known to have used
quernstones in the grinding of
mustard or mystert as it was called then
in those early days it was used
primarily or primarily to disguise the
flavor of rotten meat and it was not
until the late 1600s that it came to be
recommended in its own right there you
are dump
that's interesting that it was used
to um
to disguise the flavor of rotten meat
for a few different reasons first one
the flavor of english mustard
specifically
if you're comparing it to french mustard
american mustard any other mussels
around the world is really quite intense
and smoky not smoky hot spicy
the other thing is
i you know i don't tend to eat too much
meat nowadays but
the classic things that mustard has now
been associated with have been things
like
ham
or maybe pour yeah or certain mix it
goes very well with that it's also good
with honey mustard because you get hot
and sugar at the same time i actually
quite liking it with an apple never had
it with an apple before i'm enjoying it
i've done these last two weeks
with marmite and now coleman's mustard
both things have been in my life like my
whole life i've seen them around
but never really
you know never really
ate them or had any interest and both of
them are fantastic yeah this is
absolutely i'm going to just sit with a
one of these a little squeezy thing
and just squeeze on all food that i'll
ever have and then i'll tick off the
good ones as they as it comes along but
that is i almost can't get enough on the
bread a cheese and mustard sandwich
maybe with a little bit of onion
is absolutely fantastic but coleman's
from norfolk from norwich where
where alan partridge is one of their
most
famous sons coleman's is known for being
the iconic mustard out of england so
let's just talk for a second about
coleman specifically
it says here
from johnny claude
coleman's mustard has been based in
norfolk norwich ever since jeremiah
coleman started his mustard and flower
business in 1814 in stoke
holy cross just four miles south
of the city of norwich
the process of making almost mustard
hasn't changed
says coleman's since the beginning 60 of
the mustard seeds are locally sourced
and still undergo a thorough sampling
cleaning and drying process it looks
like it takes a lot to turn it into the
corners mustard that we know the seed
dryer building built in 1890
wow still uses original wooden
sieving equipment from the 1950s this
ensures they reach the mill in tip-top
condition they are then
crushed in break rolls sieved in pure
fries and gradually reduced to a fine
powder i wonder if the people working in
the coleman's factory have to always
wear
face masks
otherwise they will be inhaling
mustard
gas well that is probably good if there
ever you know all the things that it all
the good that it does it will stop if
they're ever going to be hysterical that
will stop that hysteria
good point or if you were bitten by a
snake while start making mustard the
mustard gas that we've come to learn
about used in the second world war
that has no correlation with mustard
in general does it it's just called that
but mustard gas yeah no that's something
else done i think it's just called it
i've almost completely finished my plate
honestly i i was i was expecting a kind
of thing yeah i kind of think it's all
right but it's it's really brilliant i
mean i put that much on that piece of
bread there
it's i don't i don't know why i'm not
eating these things all the time
i don't know either
i also
really like it
when it hits the back of your throat you
know if you if you take a little bit too
much you can sometimes knock your
sinuses out and sometimes
that's what you need i'm going to have a
little
half teaspoon of mustard
that isn't
so you're just eating it like a soup no
is this is this well is this where we've
got to
i know
no tom tom i'm gonna say that that's two
weeks in a row you've really you've
given me something great
whoa
how was that
that was intense because it's it's
intense anyway
so then just having it on its own is
extremely intense you and i like spicy
food so i can
i can handle it but
i'm some sort of digestive system
that
specifically wakes up when it gets
exposed to heat so sometimes in the
morning
if i feel like i've woken up in the
morning and maybe my dinner from the
night before is still
messing about in my digestive system
apple cider vinegar
in this
to drink
and maybe half a teaspoon of mustard
will just get everything moving oh yeah
maybe moving too fast i'm going to i'm
going to actually squeeze some in see
how that goes
i'm going to squeeze it ready
this much
quite a lot
even that i quite like yes it's actually
quite nice yeah
yeah it's intense it catches your throat
it's in my nose as well it's in my nose
but no that's good dumb let's give it
some scores
let's give you let's go first of all
um
well since this is kind of your
first big foray into english mustard i
want to hear where you land on the
flavor points first
well dom i can see why my dad was always
stirring a little bit of that powder in
the side of his plate i never actually
got it really what he was doing but that
is fantastic dom i'm giving that a 9.7
wow
taste
wow yeah
um
yeah i don't think i can beat that i
think i'm about the same i'm going to
give it a 9.7 as well it's a it's a a
flavor full of complexities goes well
with almost anything and it's fantastic
on a sandwich 9.7 for me too
aesthetics how it looks i'm going to
squeeze a little bit on in my plate
it's it's i would i would like it to be
more
the yellow of its actual tub but it's a
bit more of a kind of um
diarrhea yellow which isn't as nice as
the tub which is a nicer yellow
so
um i love the tub
the actual look i'm going to take some
points off so i'm going to say um
i like the design
7.3
nice solid score well the the
squirty tube is more of a modern day
invention to make sure that your mustard
comes out conveniently
this is what most people in britain
would know of
coleman's mustard in terms of this
jar that starts off a little bit more
narrow at the top than it does at the
bottom it has a little bit of an arse
this jar which i appreciate
yep an iconic bull
on the front of the jar i think maybe
representing the sheer strength of the
spice
of the mustard because it does knock
your brains out um the other thing i was
that i was thinking about when you were
talking about the look of it was
because they add
turmeric to the mustard which is a very
vibrant yellow i wonder if that
affects the natural color of the mustard
as well you know ah because turmeric
will stay in anything if you get
turmeric on a t-shirt or yeah on your
face it'll stain your face you know so
i hear you on the look um
and the color i'm gonna give it
i'm gonna give it an eight because i
grew up with this and i absolutely love
it so it's an eight for me
and i have to say when we're talking
about the look of it the look of the
little tin you get the powder in is
brilliant yeah
i love that that i love things that you
know i have to make this i have to do
something you know and it's got a nice
little lid on it and
and so i
i could have bumped it up but i've given
my score now and that's it
right usefulness i'm going to give this
a a good score for usefulness actually
because i feel as if i'll be squeezing
this on everything
how does this and marmite go together is
that like uh
have you ever tried it
i would i personally would give that a
pretty wide swerve i think that would be
a strange one to be honest i i welcome
your thoughts on it but i think those
two very strong flavors coming together
might be a problem but mustard with a
bunch of stuff goes amazing well mustard
and honey mustard in any kind of sugary
solution goes really well agave goes
well with a lot of different meats goes
brilliantly on a sandwich
um
goes good in pies goes good in gravies
oh here's another thing i mix it as well
sometimes into my baked beans if i'm
having beans on toast maybe i'll do a
mustardy bean you know i mean a mustardy
bean sauce
sorry salad dressing salad dressing and
pies i mean i'd say oh you've gotta have
a high usefulness i'm gonna give it a
9.8 in usefulness right yeah it's very
versatile i mean not only is the tube
versatile like you said but the powder
which like you said the little vessel
that the powder comes in with a little
flip top kind of you know hatched to it
and stuff for some reason that makes me
feel like i'm in a dickensian novel
anytime i'm working with mustard powder
exactly
strange yeah suddenly get transported
back to a christmas carol or something
but mustard powder is used a lot in
chef's kitchens just to add a little
subtlety to their dishes as well so
alongside all the things that we said
i don't think i can give it any less
than a 9.5 i think it's extremely
versatile
english mustard
and wait to hear this storm is another
just a little thing to leave it with so
jeremiah coleman um who was the great
nephew of jeremiah james coleman who i
think started it he established the
actual production factory in norwich
which is where it still exists today and
jeremiah james and his wife cared deeply
about family values and looked after the
employees like their own even
establishing a school for the children
of all their employees
and the company housing and sick benefit
for everyone who worked there isn't that
cool yeah they seem like a nice uh
sounds like a nice company as well yeah
nice group people are a family company
um
yeah and
like you said they've been around for a
long time they're one of one of the
great staples they have i don't know if
anyone knows i'll get a close-up of this
this little uh stamp here that you
sometimes see on
british
foods is a stamp by
queen elizabeth ii the monarch of
england our queen
and what that means is that if in
choosing a type of mustard the royal
family would prefer to choose
coleman's mustard and you find that on
things like
hp sauce i think it might be on marmite
i think it's on some sort of ketchup
it's on some sort of gravy browning you
see it in a lot of different places and
it basically means if given the choice
the royal family absolutely love
english mustard i love it that's a great
thing done yeah good it was a it was a
good fact there well done so coleman's
mustard another high score
[Music]
well we might have run out of time at
the end i think yeah we do have a funky
song should we shall we finish on a
funky song because i love building our
spotify playlist with funky songs let's
do it and we'll get us another song for
the spotify playlist come on dom all
right bang it on
johnny johnny
hey johnny i mean let me read out the um
the message from our from our friend
before it gets played this is from
rebecca she doesn't say where she's from
but it's rebecca with a k
and she says hi billy and dom i love the
podcast thanks i have a song to send in
that i think is pretty funky
excuse me english mustard books could
you let me know what you think the song
is called love is alive by gary wright
and she ends by saying thanks boys so
let's see
if love is alive by going right is in
any way funky
[Music]
uh
well
what do you think of that
before we before we get into that
fantastic song by rebecca
i would just like to have a little
sidebar
uh comment here which is that
all of the songs that people have sent
in up to now have been fantastic
and we've been rating them from
different levels of funk but i would
just like to reiterate
that
it just has to be funky for you which is
why it's called funky for you
of course we love funk like the next men
we love slime and family stone and
prince and james brown and all of those
classic funk makers but you might think
that brahms is funky you might think
that chopin is funky or barbra streisand
is funky or whomever so let your funky
flag fly and if you want to try and
convince billy and i
even though it might not fit into the
normal level of funk
you think it's funky we'd love to hear
that too but let's get back to the
rebecca song which i did believe was
pretty darn funky it was kind of like
slow sexy funky dom this is a kind of
song that if it was on in a club i'd had
a few drinks i would think i was a
better dancer than i was
i would be up dancing to it thinking i'm
really good at dancing to this song but
i wouldn't like to see that record even
played back to me yeah not interesting
that there was a point in our lives not
that long ago we can still remember it
where going to a club
and dancing for four or five hours was
kind of the expectation
now i would be absolutely mortified if
someone said to me next friday night you
have to dance for four and a half hours
pretty much non-stop unless you're
getting drinks from the bar or going to
the toilet i would be horrified would
you you would need some coleman's
mustard just to get your your system
going that's what you need
brilliant but um yeah that was funky
like you said that was kind of like um
if you're in a if you're in a club or a
bar it would be playing in the
in the room just off from the main room
kind of where people are hanging out
maybe catching the catching the vibe
it's not too hectic that you have to
immediately run to the dance floor but
very kind of like
like a you know a vibe type thing um
i like that that's funny you're saying
that because i was going to say
did he think it felt a little bit like
the singer was a little far away from
the mic like he was singing the song
next door
so i get what you mean but it was called
love is alive by gary wright i've never
heard that before and i didn't think it
was funky sexy funky and i'm going to
give a i'm going to give her a mark dom
you ready okay
and and again it's from brahms as not
funky to prince
at the top of the funk
scale yeah i'm going to give a
parliament
funky
and sexy funky and i want to dance to it
there you go
i like that you picked parliament
because parliament were able to kind of
create a mood weren't they create a vibe
kind of like
you've suddenly found yourself in
parliament world and that's what it felt
like with this guy
alex was he's like all right yeah sit
down i'll take it from here i'm the funk
meister general i'm gonna give it
a
late no
mid 1970's
share
level of funk oh
when she was herself yeah not not like
the height of cher's funkiness with
sonny where she where she's going off a
head-on funk i mean she's just coming
down the side of having established
herself
as a funky gibbon and now she's kind of
you know relaxing into it but she hasn't
found the autotune yet no she's not
there yet no and she's not i love it
she's not on a massive
naval
carrier that takes aeroplanes and
possibly submarines and people across
large breadths of oceans wearing a
negligee
and singing to like two or three
thousand uh armed forces people well how
did how did that
happen do you know what i mean
the captain of that ship would never
wear suspenders like that no way no
could get caught in a rudder or anything
you should also never besmirch the uh
american navy by wearing a hat so akimbo
i don't know if you remember but her
captain's hat was not here it was kinda
no you know it was a bit saucy it's a
jaunty angle yeah yeah absolutely dumb
well that was a fantastic show dog that
was lovely meeting kayla finding all
about that
mustard oh another another success on
billy and tom eat the world uh
we haven't had a bad one since the
smoked oysters maybe we need when people
send in your ideas from around the world
of food and it doesn't have to be good
if it's something that you remember from
your childhood that you thought oh i'd
never want to eat that again me and dom
will have a go at it send it in and
don't forget to rate review and
subscribe would be very thankful
also you had said at some point bills
we're gonna make that
licorice
watery sugary solution maybe we can have
that on billion dollar meat the world at
some point
absolutely we'll have sugar only water
it'll take me two weeks to make as i
remember it
but we'll have that on very soon
thanks guys for helping us get to a
hundred thousand on youtube keep
subscribing we're gonna get to a million
by next week
and also like billy said wherever you
get your podcast whether that's spotify
or anywhere that you get hold of your
podcast if you could rate review and
subscribe to us it helps billy and i
make more episodes and makes us feel all
warm and fluffy inside you can also send
voicemails to us at speak pipe forward
slash the friendship onion
dom go and get on a plane and i'll see
you next week in the studio thank
goodness i love me and lots of love to
all of you bye bye
[Music]